hoje vou tentar responder à pergunta que
mais vezes me fazem quando encontrou
nesta neste evento já me fizeram essa
pergunta várias vezes e quando me
entrevistam e perguntei será que
matemática realmente provoca queda deveu
se a pergunta é se é perguntei por que
que a matemática é um bicho papão será
que o bicho papão realmente existe
porque tanta gente não gosta de
matemática como resolver o problema da
matemática
quantas pessoas aqui e não gostam de
matemática já sentiram edifício papão
antebraço
é impressionante a matemática é um
problema muita gente que escolhe toda
uma carreira em função da matemática
pessoas que estavam ser uma certa coisa
escolhem ser outra escolhem fazer toda
uma carreira ou atos por não gostarem de
mata que para tentar evitar a matemática
e isso é fato um problema é execuções
provocou um calafrio muita gente não
imagina a quantidade de anos que eu já
vi estarem prestes a terminar o curso e
terem os problemas matemáticos os
primeiros anos para fazer talvez
centenas delas
os editores acreditam que um livro
divulgação matemática que têm concessões
faz cair as vendas projetadas a fato um
problema aqui isso tem um nome a os
especialistas em ciências da educação
chama ansiedade matemática e pode ser
vendida há uns testes pisa coordenado
pela acer e merda e não só performance
dos alunos a matemática mas também a
perceção que austen da forma como é
patente está ensinado das matérias que
estão a ser ensinadas e medo ea
ansiedade nós hoje sabemos que portugal
2003 para 2012 vou imensos nós hoje
estamos na merda e essencialmente junto
com países como o canadá ou a noruega
mas há países muito piores do que nós
por exemplo a tunísia o brasil ou
argentina e em contrapartida apenas
muito
jorge por exemplo ou anda que está no
topo mas pois é a dinamarca ou suécia
onda o flu teve mente nós
- ansiedade na matemática é também muito
curioso que é a cidade distribuídos de
forma igual entre os sexos as mulheres
em geral em praticamente todos os países
do mundo são mais ansiosa do que os
homens
é também curioso que nos países onde há
menos ansiedade matemática são
exatamente os países onde a amplitude
maior e ninguém sabe por que eu diria
que um dos problemas da matemática ou
talvez o maior problema é ter muitos
problemas são muitos bicho papão não há
um só problema que era um deus tem uma
certa contribuição para o estado coisas
mas nenhum deus explica completamente o
fenômeno eu já identifica e talvez
dezenas deus vou te falar sobre alguns
mas ficariam muitos outros por dizer ah
ah ah problemas que são óbvios a
matemática é difícil é óbvio agora será
que ser um problema
não há tantas outras coisas difíceis
tocar um instrumento é difícil ser
atleta de alta competição é difícil
conquistar uma mulher é difícil e há
tanta gente que tenta fazer a frustração
também normalmente tem ficado como um
dos problemas claro abstração é um
problema matemático que se trata não há
como fugir a isso é matemática é e
punição abstração a matemática eo que
sobra de uma ideia quando nós primeiros
e tiramos tudo que é concreta essa ideia
o brincar eu dizia que a matemática em
adotar o mesmo numa coisas diferentes o
que eu queria dizer com isto é
essencialmente está matemática e que
quando nós subimos o nível dos tratos
nos permite criar ligações é entre as
coisas no cérebro infelizmente não está
preparado para lidar com isso nosso
cérebro foi inicialmente preparados
preferida é o nosso corpo e nossa
relação com uma ideia mais tarde foi
também é feito para digerir a nossa
relação com os outros temas
inclusivamente para os próprios para a
linguagem para ter empatia com os outros
mas não temos uma parte da abstração
isso foi uma coisa é uma coisa pouco
natural do nosso cérebro e fato esse é
um problema agora será que esse é o
problema mais uma vez não
poesia é abstração uma emoção e
abstração conhecem ao mais abstrato do
que música é música talvez armas a
estrada que nós conhecemos e toda a
gente praticamente gosta de música
portanto este não pode ser o problema
uma das vezes das razões que leva talvez
mais essa ansiedade é o fato da
matemática ser vista como uma vida da
nossa inteligência pela sociedade
a minha avó ela dizia que quem é bomba
de que muito do resto e todas as avós
têm o facto de saber de experiência
feito mas infelizmente ela estava errada
a matemática não mero não é uma medida
de 900 e nós temos muitas outras
outras vertentes que não são avaliadas
pela matemática é uma inteligência
emocional memória tetra e portanto facto
matemática não é uma medida da nossa
inteligência mas a sociedade em geral
nós vemos como medida da cintura agência
diz faz com que seja muito complicada a
nossa relação com matemática e é por
isso por exemplo na minha opinião que se
geram esta divisão entre as pessoas
gostam muito matemáticas uma imposição
matemática e as pessoas que não gostou
nada de matemática e matemática não
haver uma e termo porque porque a
relação é complicada quem entra com o pé
direito tendo a forçar a sua autoestima
e centenas ser cada vez melhor está cada
vez mais e essa pessoa tem de gostar
muito de matemática quem entra com o pé
esquerdo no início tende é dar se mal e
tende é não ir à luta ou seja tendem a
preferir dizer eu não gosto de
matemática o ano em vista o suficiente
de matemática e ainda treinamento de
fato tem um problema e tenha mesmo de
trabalhar e de fato é este é na minha
opinião uma das razões porque gera tanta
animação era tanta ansiedade
a matemática é por natureza competitiva
e não há como fugir a isso nós quando
estamos na escola atendemos olhar
próximo vai haver se aqueceu já computou
estado ciências
atendemos a comparar resultados ver quem
chega primeiro mesmo a nível
profissional nós matemáticos
profissionais tendem a estar
constantemente a competir e ver quem
chega primeiro resultado porque daí se
tornou num cinema é e e talvez não seja
assim preciso tanta competição em certas
áreas a competição é saudável
em matemática eu diria que aconteceu
mais e não era necessário tanto eu diria
que uma das formas de talvez frear um
pouco esta convicção era uma medida
muito simples quer deixar publicar as
notas dos exames
eu sou avaliado na minha faculdade o bom
desempenho é avaliado tem inclusivamente
uma nota
mas o sistema de avaliação do desempenho
da minha faculdade prevê que essa nota
não seja pública nem sequer os meus
colegas sabem nota é essa
há todo um sistema de divulgação de
resultados em que sabem médias de forma
que o sistema possa ser avaliados mas a
minha nota não é pública é nota dos
professores do secundário e básico
também tem uma nota de 1 a 10
e essa nota também não é pública porque
nós vamos publicar os nossos porque nós
os nossos professores ea que achamos
perfeitamente natural que a nossa nota
não seja pública é chamas que é natural
publicar as notas dos nossos alunos é
aqui uma certa agressão na verdade o
aluno tem direito de ter o conhecimento
forma é individual e privada dessa nota
e poder gerir e se essa informação como
quiser pode contar a quem quiser aos
amigos e à família
se quiser muitos pais ou até mesmo isso
é questionável
outro problema tem a ver com o facto de
as pessoas acreditarem que a matemática
é uma questão de educação que há pessoas
para a matemática que nasceram para a
matemática ea pessoas que não nasceram
para a matemática está totalmente errado
um dos melhores exemplos talvez seja eu
é o próprio até o de até o 12º até
entrar para a faculdade tinha não tinha
notas brilhantes tenha tinham cento a
passar lembro por exemplo novembro todas
as notas é da minha escola mas lembra
por exemplo do 12º um ano antes entrava
matemática quando sair o primeiro que o
primeiro trimestre é com o negativa a
matemática
mais tarde seria para matemática um
pouco por acaso e de repente é
apaixonado por matemática e conselho
está muito mato e se por acaso não
tivesse entrado em matemática
teria sido possível concluir outras
coisas hoje não teria aquela coisa que
as pessoas mudam
- não vim fato não foi talento facto foi
trabalho é também uma certa paixão e
isso gerou uma certa motivação mas no
fim foi trabalho não tinha chips com com
uma capacidade especial para fazer
matemática
claro que são também tem de ser pensada
é nós temos sempre que pensar a forma
como nós explicamos isso temos
importantes é pensar a e e e refletir
sobre isso
uai está em ter uma frase que eu acho
que é famosa eu disse que educação e
tudo sobra depois nos esquecermos do que
aprendemos na escola e impressionantes
por quando nós olhamos para a nossa
prestação enquanto educadores matemática
alunos desta frase queremos que está
quase tudo errado
praticamente não sobra nada quando nós
não esquecemos de como resolver e que os
sonhos se eu perguntar ao cidadão com
que ela se lembra das aulas de
matemática eu vai dizer não sair a
tabuada o aquela coisa dos catetos
hipótese musas quadrados 10 não sei o
que é dos outros e pouco mais ficou né
nós temos de pensar e temos de
urgentemente refletirmos nós talvez até
os matemáticos mas talvez entender essa
essa foi só a todas as sociedades de um
parto coisas que nós queremos que fique
na cabeça das pessoas quando elas
esquecem de como resolver equações
quando eu é quando eu era quando estava
é preparar o programa de matemática na
televisão é antes do programa começar a
ser transmitido contava as pessoas que
fazer um programa sobre matemática na
televisão e invariavelmente as pessoas
me viam a primeira é é a imagem que as
pessoas tenham do que ser é que ser um
programa para crianças
é curioso porque o programa é fato para
adultos
eu passo na seqüência é desenhado para
um público adulto nós temos tendência a
achar a hora que é matemática é uma
coisa crianças e não é porque daí não
saiu um é uma coisa muito curiosa e isso
eu vou contar o que aconteceu aqui neste
mês que vem talvez umas três vezes
foi com tanto que quando nós temos na
conversa com alguém e o tema cair na
matemática invariavelmente o tema cai na
escola cai na forma como nós fomos
ensinados é quando é que nós deixarmos
tudo estará na temática qual era o
professor não estávamos mais qual é uma
pessoa que nós estávamos - e esse
curioso porque não acontece nas outras
áreas nos falamos sobre economia falamos
sobre economia não falamos sobre o
ensino da economia
se falamos sobre história fará um filme
sobre história sobre psicologia não
falamos sobre o ensino da psicologia e
por que é que acontece com a matemática
é pouco porque justamente as pessoas não
tenham imaginar eu não tenho uma ideia
do que é do que matemática dá algumas
idéias para conversarem sobre matemática
e de facto é um falhanço da forma como
nós estamos a ensinar matemática de 2003
para 2012
no teste seja nós tivemos aqui em
portugal um dos maiores progressos é de
todos os países avaliados portugal
estava em destaque nos relatórios e eu
estou convencido que é a diferença
aconteceu porque é o vantagens várias
razões mas eu tenho a impressão que o
ponto-chave tem a ver com o facto da em
os 215 anos foram os aliados tinham em
média pais de 40 anos que tenham cursado
o seu processo é sua educação antes do
25 de abril
em 2012 os pais dessas 10 e 12 anos e 15
anos tinham mais uma vez 40 anos mas já
teria iniciado o processo é de educação
depois do 25 de abril
de fato o bumbum né não mas essa
impressão depois do 25 de abril de 2003
para 2012
nós duplicamos o número de licenciados
em portugal ou seja em 2012 é um dos 115
anos sentia-se envolvido por uma
comunidade uma sociedade diz que
entendia o que estava a fazer e isso é
super importante e essa é uma das razões
que algumas das vertentes alguns destes
bicho papão vão ser tão difíceis de
erradicar portanto serem replicadas
geração para geração
nós temos de ir educando uma uma geração
para que a próxima se sinta envolvida
gente que compreende e que quem entenda
melhor essa matemática para concluir
será que o bicho propondo a matemática
existe mesmo
a resposta é sim e é real mas existe só
dentro da nossa cabeça e portanto cabe a
cada um nós acabar com ela